holy bunco's kids look out the keep it
moving tour is adding new dates
we're coming to a city near you
come and see us some stand-up and we
play ayg at the end of the show with the
crowd we answer your garbage questions
we've got some trash so far but i know i
know
there's deeper garbage out there around
the country oh yeah so come on out and
see us kippy tell them what they need to
know oh baby we're all over the place uh
providence rhode island august 11th
boston massachusetts august 12th new
brunswick new jersey august 25th down
tomatoes timonium maryland magooby's
august 26th couple of crabs and we're
going to tejas baby
uh september 21st we'll be in san
antonio texas september 22nd we'll be in
houston texas
september 23rd through the 25th austin
texas for the moon tower comedy festival
and i ain't done yet august 26 will be
at four dallas fort worth texas what
then we're bringing it back to long
island baby what in all uh september
30th and then we're coming home the boys
are the chickens are coming home to
roost baby
october 27th we're going to be in
philadelphia pennsylvania and then back
down to tejas uh november 5th through
the 7th for skankfest south get those
tickets the link will be in the
description welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage
the show where you find out if your
favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage sure is a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they go to be classy or
if they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a beautiful day we're down here at
antoine's basement she's upstairs she's
got olympic fever she's asking me for
two grand for what because she wants to
put it on this french fencing guy that
she says is a lot of luck so i don't
know what's going on over there my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me
so today that went nowhere
he is the ceo of ru garbage he's
international businessman he has his
toes in many different ponds around the
globe it's going to be in europe next
week
so if you're from any uh uh
law enforcement agency sure you want to
track them down it's a good time to get
them to land the plane somewhere kevin
james ryan everybody what's up interpol
uh hey happy to be here as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
as you know those numbers are true to
roof [ __ ] cooking baby then
patreon.com
it's where the where the bread gets
buttered you know what i mean rubber
hits a little bit of ghee over there
that's why the coke hits the nose uh
you can sign up you get bonus episodes
at ayg you get episodes of hard feelings
which is a whole nother podcast and then
we do live streams with their top tier
members every month it's a good [ __ ]
time plus you get full uh extended clips
of the live shows we're putting on it
that's right baby come out say the time
we love you how about a quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire he's the
magic man makes us all look good give it
up for the pride of chicago scene and
now the pride of the new york scene new
transplant certain block in astoria
it's t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen
what's up dudes yeah i'm real big on
oh i gotta bleep that [ __ ]
he's probably not even the biggest comic
in his building
i got roaches with bigger careers than
me man
gang that's either here nor there
because we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly and i mean
incredibly special guests gonna be a fun
one here with us today we're so excited
he is a very funny stand-up comedian
podcaster and author la di da okay he is
the writer of the book running the light
that everybody absolutely loves he's the
host of the chubby behemoth podcast he's
going to be here in new york city
filming a comedy central presents and he
has a brand new hour special coming out
september 7th called waiting for death
to claim us but the big question about
his mind today is he garbage he's been
hitting the jewel like a radio operator
in world war ii do me a favor give it up
for the one the only mr sam talent
everybody hey fellas sammy what a
pleasure thank you so much for having me
thanks for coming in i feel like i was
holding my breath that whole one that
was a long one
and i was teetering on the verge of
lunch in it like four or five times
picked up on that i can see i can see it
looks like you black out a little bit
and you come to you don't know where you
are i have an eyelid closed i can feel
samsung
he got that twitch in his eye that you
can't control we all smelt toast
yeah you had such a big stroke i smell
toast
buddy thank you so much for coming in
and sitting down with us we're so
excited about this what is the the
origin story here uh sam talent
i'm reading for sam talent where does a
gentleman like you hail from i'm from
elizabeth colorado on the eastern plains
of colorado
uh the eastern plains this guy's an
author i don't know what to tell you
the lights just lowered what was the
hail oh no
the eastern plains what have i done
i was born on a soft autumn evening yeah
yeah i'm uh it's a town of less than a
thousand people wow about an hour from
the kansas border okay uh our biggest uh
money maker is the rodeo oh yeah we're
rodeo town
[Laughter]
biggest export of jihad
you said gee earlier all right yeah
that's true yeah like some ghee yeah
um yeah just uh you know football
methamphetamine
the good kind sounds like america to me
goddammit oh yeah red white and blue
baby so small very small town oh
incredibly small high school would you
graduate with 86 80s we were the biggest
[Laughter]
how far away from like denver paint me a
picture if i don't know okay colorado
springs is uh is down here in the the
middle of the state and then denver is
that the state this is the state of
colorado on my wrist right here holy
[ __ ] cut it print it we got all we need
yeah i know state tattoos
and my area code
the reppin of the area codes has always
been garbage it's bad news especially if
it's not like a known area 305 i guess
two one two seven eight nine three
representing eastern plains colorado
yeah we're one of those places that it's
called elbert county it's not elizabeth
yeah i'm from a county you go the county
yeah yeah yeah i've been to county
really oh yeah
he said that he said that it was [ __ ]
community college there's only 85 people
out there they got to arrest somebody
what the [ __ ]
all right sam it's your turn pack it in
all right let me get my lucky strikes
and uh yeah i just we are
we were really literally known for our
methamphetamine the kids would go to the
old abandoned air force base
and steal the fuel from the old tanks
there and then make primo crystal holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's unbelievable
and i didn't know we had abandoned air
force they don't want you to know
they're not broadcasting that [ __ ] a lot
of the dod budget goes to that
but yeah we're we're equidistant from
colorado springs and denver so it was a
bedroom community so people would uh
work in denver and colorado springs and
their kids would grow up there
okay yeah i gotcha bedroom community is
much better than like
rural [ __ ]
a place you don't stay
[Laughter]
god damn yeah they would go and steal
the jets it's gotta be a good jet fuel
mess oh dude i mean i've dabbled yeah
yeah really well yeah you know it's prom
you want to be ready for the dance floor
yeah i want to be an idiot all nine of
you on the dance floor that's right
steal a light bulb
get out there holy hit the buffet dance
it up a little bit no buffet on that net
you're not eating for days
yeah
god damn that's crazy and where was
where was the market just so
was there a huge meth problem in town or
were they selling this well so i-70 is
the i-7925 i-70 goes east-west so lyman
was on i-70 which is about 45 minutes
away
and lyman was a big truck stop so they
would move the meth through lyman uh all
over these great american states damn
yeah but i mean mostly i think it was
domestic a lot of the kids were getting
blasted yeah getting high on their own
supply type deal
and then luckily pills came in when my
sister was in school so there you go
that was when i was a kid pills were
like i mean like we were height of the
[ __ ] pan like you know the epidemic
yeah east coast has the pills and out
there we have the tweak yeah yeah
charlotte's kind of jealous stuff really
well benzos are a lot more fun
[Laughter]
yeah benzo's in a couple of [ __ ] pops
called another oh yeah two bud lights
and a percocet yeah
good morning and good night that looks
yeah yeah dude that looks a lot a lot
classier than siphoning fuel out of an
f-14 oh yeah
wait
and your head is still in the jets
in your head they're still jets
why wouldn't they just strip the copper
out of the chest
or sell the jet yeah right oh yeah it's
tough to find a jet fence
oh i got a guy in delaware that can move
a c-130
uh holy [ __ ] all right so what is your
mom and dad and let me ask you this
brother sisters so was there like this
like was it a shitty town or was it like
a nice town i think that it i would
describe it as a quaint community with
issues okay uh i think that a lot of the
kids there knew that there was was
problems but a lot of the parents were
so busy you know raising equestrian
horses and uh
that
when i tell people about elizabeth
they don't understand because they're
like oh i've heard of elizabeth it's
nice like i've driven through there
before okay like well yeah after sundown
it's got you in freak city
here i yeah i painted the perfect
picture i get exactly what you're
talking about but uh mom and dad my dad
was uh until i was 13 he was a you know
fall down uh sip sap guy but then he got
clean
uh and he worked at walmart unloading
trucks okay for like those three years
when he got sober then he got his
teaching degree became a great teacher
really yeah yeah talk about turning at
the [ __ ] around i mean he wasn't like uh
a dangerous drunk he was like oh the car
broke down let's go hitchhiking drunk
you know yeah yeah like we got to get
out of here somehow
like my dad the best way to describe it
is he was like moon people at the bank
trunk
it was pretty fun that's a fun like he
liked having a good time great bit yeah
and it sucks when your mom's mad at him
for doing that yeah because it's like
he's the funnest man alive yeah
yeah yeah are they still together oh
yeah okay yeah happily married really oh
for sure uh-huh my mom you know she's
she's no angel
my mom's retirement has just been white
russians when she wakes up wow yeah yeah
they rule
they're fun my dad you know he's he's a
colorado sober so he'll still eat too
many mushrooms on christmas and then
have to lay down
mushrooms on christmas yeah yeah yeah i
like how he said he's like yeah i got
his act together just you know
psychedelics on family functions yeah
it's fun holy [ __ ] yeah my dad will be
like you gotta see this rug that i
bought
[Laughter]
half a quiche and an eighth on [ __ ]
christmas day yes
white russians huh so they're both
retired they're both retired brothers
and sisters what do you got i have a
sister sophia okay younger older younger
than me how much younger she's an adult
she's three years younger than me she's
three years old yeah okay so she's out
of the house as well she lives in denver
uh she runs a spa she's very good at
what she does okay pretty good there you
go and what'd your mom do for a living
before she was retired so my mom worked
at the federal reserve in denver okay
and when we were born she was like no
thank you i don't want to drive that far
okay i went back to school became a
landscape architect that didn't pay at
all she did that for a while for the
county and then went back to work for
the fed for the retirement money okay
yeah that's pretty good pretty eclectic
i mean squad federal reserve yeah
federal reserve and then the dad doing
mushrooms is a right turn but landscape
architect your dad
was an alcoholic got himself sober yeah
became a teacher uh-huh sister runs her
own business well she runs a spa for a
bunch of uh malaysian people okay all
right fair enough
that's not chill out
yeah she's a shift manager you know what
i mean exactly yeah
that's still pretty good did you guys go
to the rodeo on a regular basis oh yeah
so that was like the culture so the
rodeo was once a year and it was the hub
of culture in in elbert county all right
and it was cool because if you went
there as a kid like 13 14 15 it was
there was no rules because the adults
were all [ __ ] wasted the cops had
their hands full and like there'd be a
skull tank or a skull a tent there and
they'd just whip cans a skull at you
yeah so we're all just got big
horseshoes in wandering around finishing
empties on the tables
yeah jeez now was this
uh event on like a circuit
no so the elizabeth stampede is its own
thing no but i mean it's so but it's a
big deal compared to like a regular
sport it's the only thing that happens
in elizabeth so it's the super bowl for
sure yeah okay
people are coming in from all over uh
you know it's the first time you ever
like make out with a girl while mark
garth brooks rodeo plays you know
both have dip in your mouth oh yeah
hopefully she has wintergreen yeah
i got skull apple because i'm trying to
be healthy
my doctor said two pieces of fruit a day
have you ever seen anyone get like
really tuned up at the rodeo like like
[ __ ] up by a bull or anything like
that oh all the time really yeah my
buddy clay raider was a mutton buster i
don't understand one word of that
sentence
that's funny my aunt was a mutton buster
i've seen her only fans
[Laughter]
mutton busting is when you're a young
cowboy you ride the back of a mutton a
male sheep
and you have a helmet on and you strap
yourself to the back of it and go oh
yeah wait that's what mutton is is sheep
yeah yeah so when people order mutton at
a restaurant yeah they're getting sheep
male sheep
and i don't remember if mutton is
castrated or not i think a mutton is
castrated okay yeah nothing wrong with
it
come on folks what are we doing here you
still got it
but yeah he uh graduated from mutton
busting do i think he got a rodeo
scholarship to texas tech and got
completely eviscerated by a [ __ ] bull
his freshman year jesus
can't walk well at all anymore damn but
clay his brother dusty and his father
cecil okay these raiders
they're known for raising hell and
all of them are crippled from rodeo
accidents really yeah yeah
generationally texas tech has a pro as a
rodeo program a lot of uh places out
west have like a big way out of
elizabeth was getting a rodeo
scholarship
that's awesome
nuts i want to see that movie i like
donald trump dude i have the screenplay
yeah for sure he pulls it out it's weird
like an urban cowboy no no urban yeah
who's your first choice uh to play clay
raider is that who it is it's about him
it's i mean loosely yeah yeah yeah we're
not giving this guy points on the back
yeah no bleep his name is
[Laughter]
did you ever want to get into rodeo like
even as a kid
dude no it sucks did you play football
oh yeah so really state lineman uh kind
of i signed a letter of intent for cu
but i hurt myself wrestling so i
couldn't play in college okay yeah now
how did the team work with how many kids
were on the team if you only graduated
with 87 well that was just my class
obviously right so the team was very
good we ran a power eye offense nice
dominant run block it was fun i was a
right tackle for a left-handed
quarterback
played football from third grade all the
way through i mean i played basketball i
threw shot put i did everything year
round gotcha so it wasn't like one of
those small towns where it's like they
only play with like seven on seven
because they can't get the kids you guys
had a decent program that could get the
kids in all yeah i mean the rest of the
the towns in my county were eight-man
football and then agate was six-man
football and those games are just it's a
it doesn't make any sense yeah that's
nice it's like a basketball game oh for
sure yeah yeah and they're playing you
know both ways there's like a dystopian
man it really oh yeah it's a [ __ ]
post apocalyptic yeah the field's all
dirt and [ __ ] yeah no yes yeah yeah if
you crash plane in the end
kids are siphoning
that's why they're so good
we're cooking at halftime
holy [ __ ] i didn't peg you as an athlete
to be honest with you wow okay yeah well
no one does yeah yeah yeah
allstate nonetheless yeah did you end up
going to college i did attend university
yeah which one metro state university
i know dude it's funny how you say you
say university yeah
i did attend university i was at
cambridge where are we talking
i went to a little school called
dartmouth
uh yeah metro state university is a
commuter campus right sounds like a bad
murphy movie or something like that oh
yeah yeah kid and play were my
professors
and it was seriously like there was no
it was all white kids growing up and
some latinos and like going to metro
right in downtown denver was a real
culture shock yeah yeah because it was
one of these places where like
you have 55 year old widowers who are
like doing their second chance
they're going back and then you have a
bunch of deadbeats and burnouts who
couldn't get into university of colorado
denver
so yeah it was uh i did not graduate no
how long did it last all right so i
re-enrolled i'm i'm going to graduate
now in december what what yeah come on
thank you i need i needed three i needed
uh three classes these talents don't
quit i'll tell you that everybody keep
coming back
well after the book came out some like
small liberal arts schools were like
would you consider teaching what and i
was like i guess i would and they're
like cool where'd you go to school and i
was like well i don't have a degree and
they're like never mind so what do you
know about the rodeo yeah yeah
can i teach barrel roping
if you know one thing about rodeo two
though is the girls in the pants that
was a huge deal at the road what's that
mean so like girls at the rodeo are all
the sweetheart of the rodeo gear is what
they'd call it they're just suited uh
they have very very tight wranglers and
then those like button-ups they would
tie off at the waist so it was a very
horny place wow i'm not going to picture
it oh it's great it was right there at
casey jones park uh and it was just
it was a [ __ ] fest
people would just go off into the woods
bang
girls would come back with their hair
[ __ ] up and like you know not stoked
and the guys would come back like
smoking winston jesus oh yeah like like
adults you would see the adults doing
this adults kids yeah yeah
real country
it was incredibly country did you know
was anybody in your family uh or do you
do you know anybody that was one of the
clowns no but i do know rodeo clowns
really yeah yeah the ken diggs were all
rodeo clowns
he's from the time he's from he's from
the type of like part of the country
where it's like families do professions
like the kendricks the the richardsons
yeah were you ever deputized for a posse
i would have loved to have been
man no but our sheriff did get uh in
trouble for embezzling a bunch of money
to buy hot dogs for people who built his
house
that sentence got more insane as it went
on yeah this guy had affected a real
high-stakes scheme huh yeah yeah oh yeah
talk about big money this thing went all
the way to the top you thought madoff
was back yeah he was our dare officer
and when he got deposed my dad was like
yeah he spent like 30 grand on hot dogs
for that barn raising jesus yeah that's
something to get you kicked out of
office oh yeah
this is city funds to use for the hot
dogs i mean it was it was upwards of 30
grand but i don't think all of that 30
grand yeah i was gonna yeah that was the
lot that's what showed up at the the
expense report it was thirty thousand
dollars on hot dog right oh i'm such an
idiot i thought there was like there was
like a barn full of hot dogs yeah so did
i kinda i thought he was just trying to
be a nice gonna be so easy to rip you
two off it is going to be incredibly
easy to pull the wool over your eyes
this is insane
but as a kid though i was so naive i was
like just thinking about the hot oh yeah
that's what i was literally thinking
about a whole building full of hot dogs
i gotta find this hot dog cash
you know they never found most of the
hot dogs they're still out there digging
in the woods for them and [ __ ] you and
your buddies like goonies
bunch of kids with a bunch of mustard
packets walking down the railroad tracks
legend has it at midnight you can still
hear them grilling
smell them at night oh yeah oh man
that's funny raycon wireless earbuds oh
yeah i'll say it again bozo three magic
words that have changed my life
raycon wireless earbuds okay pretty sure
that's more than three but continue it's
three
your words maybe
kept me a technicality the point is i
was the idiot
come in here
play my music watch my videos
annoying everybody around you yes
raycon earbuds were built for you raycon
earbuds might have saved this podcast
you have no idea you guys not killing
the severity of that statement the big
man would come in here without your pods
just playing whatever he wants to watch
it tick tocks his dirty movies whatever
he does
ray content on some of your buds he's
using them
all pieces everything's right in the
world and they're absolutely fantastic
they fit perfectly they sound amazing
yeah top quality unbelievable so glad
that i waited this long to get them yeah
also you know a lot i mean i i never
leave the house without ear buds and now
raycon sent them to us that's that's a
go-to fashion baby that's what i'm
rocking it's good stuff i listen to
podcasts and relax i'll put them on if
i'm doing work around the house whatever
pumping up need some music going on a
run that hasn't happened in a while but
still
um so let me tell you right now raycons
are the best way to listen to whatever
you listen to baby uh they come with a
bun with a bunch of gel tips for your
comfort unlike some other brands they
don't stick out of your ears real sleek
very comfortable 32-hour battery life so
now you can listen to what you want when
you want for a very long time and they
start at half the price of other premium
audio brands good stuff but they sound
just as good and raycon's come with a
45-day happiness guarantee so you really
can't lose give them a shot you'll see
what we mean baby
uh you can create your own soundtrack
with raycon right now are you garbage
listeners get 15 percent off their
raycon order at buy raycon dot com slash
garbage that's buy raycon
r-a-c-o-n dot-com slash garbage to save
15 percent on records baby bye raycondon
by raycon.com garbage now back to the
show
holy [ __ ] all right let's get into some
are you garbage question where where are
you at now where you living i'm living
in fort collins colorado okay north my
wife's uh she's a doctor so
her she's in her three years of
residency what kind of doc she's a
family medicine doctor holy [ __ ]
emphasis on women's health but you know
i was not expecting that neither was i
i don't think she was either yeah
yeah the odds on that were plus 1500
[Laughter]
it was not a lock i thought you're going
to say i live in a one bedroom in toluca
lakes
no i live in like the nicest home i've
ever lived in in fort collins an hour
north of denver it's where colorado
state university is nice yeah we got a
garden in front a garden in back i'm
eating my own squash that's right yeah
man damn where'd you meet a doctor i met
her at a house party and she was on a
doctor at the time okay she had a rat
tail and a bottle of codeine cough syrup
and she was friendly with it and then uh
she managed to turn it all around
they turn it around that's when you
think they're dead they pop right back
come back even stronger and smarter oh
you can't kill her she's from detroit
i met her in a bank her and her friends
were robbing the place yeah it's a nice
mask
holy [ __ ] now she's a pediatrician
holy [ __ ] no kids though no kids all
right and i'm holding off on that as
long as possible okay sure i get you
i get you
all right um do your parents still live
in the same house that you grew up in
yes how they do all right what was the
grocery store that your mom went to uh
we went to geeson's market
geeson's market yeah geese's market was
cool it was in uh right in the middle of
elizabeth and then when safeway came and
opened up about five miles away it
obliterated all of geeson's
was geeson's just like a one
like or was it a chain or was it one
oh yeah there was jack easton who played
course they're my father
[Laughter]
hell of a hold'em player if you ask me
oh no he was bad his brother dennis was
very good but jack would just get
fleeced
this would all make sense if you grew up
a hundred years ago i know yeah yeah
yeah
oh the jenkins yeah they were the
blacksmiths yeah can i get that
sarsaparilla
i don't sit with him back to the door
fellas
we're going to switch this around
if i open the door and there was a horse
sitting outside tied up i wouldn't be
that surprised i'm not gonna lie i'd
also have an apple for it
my best friend my best friend my like
next next door there was a cow and i
would go feed it boo berry what's
blueberry blueberry's a cereal oh yeah
like count chocolate oh really yeah and
that was like
my friend was this cow who lived next
door you were a boo berry family yeah
wow i know you don't see them quite
often no that was refreshing never even
heard of it that was something well you
had count chocula you had uh
frankenberry and you had boo berry which
was the
that was the hardest one to find i think
it there was an abundance
really
geesens was one of these places that it
was doing
you really did
i mean to have blueberry out there oh
yeah i couldn't find that in philly no
well it's a major it's a major blueberry
market that doesn't look good oh
that looks bad they're probably the best
cereal ever it's very good all of them
because they are what the difference is
they have the marshmallows with the
lucky charms but their actual cereal
thing is that is the corn right so it's
real you can tell how sugary and bad it
is for you it has like porous like the
way it soaks up milk it's still a little
crunchy but it has the mushiness too oh
and that's your boo berry minute with hp
geez walk down memory lane
dude that's the only guy i can do three
minutes on blueberry yeah
i'm telling you it was really it was
very good hmm holy [ __ ] all right
so we okay so gizens yeah that's right
it's not bad sounds like it's a nice
market the town sounds nice
so that sounds quaint i like it it does
sound it does sound clean i see what
you're saying with the meth problem and
stuff like that yeah but all in all
i mean there was there was a
slaughterhouse in town that went defunct
and that was where everyone worked
and then when the slaughterhouse dropped
out people had to scramble to figure out
what to do there's one of these places
where there's a population of less than
a thousand but there's three there's a
meineke
unlike there's like three different auto
parts shops and o'reilly and meineke one
of those situations
would you say the town successfully
scrambled when the when the when the
plant closed oh they did it
yeah yeah all right now i don't know the
pivot was tough because i want to be
honest with you despite the rodeo and
everything we've heard i'm he's still
classy
well that's on you but sure he just hit
his jewel
[Laughter]
but he tucked it down
he's not flaunting it so i can't get mad
at it uh what'd you get on your sats
uh i did not take the scts took the a c
t what'd you get 32. that's pretty good
if i recall that could yeah yeah yeah
yeah i did very well in standardized
tests would you consider yourself a good
student are you a good student
like
yeah i was i took the uh
you know all the uh ap classes and stuff
really yeah
yeah i was a very good student
okay single family home you guys lived
in
yeah uh the house was built in 1880 and
then there was a barn you guys just
giggling
he answers every question like it's the
first sentence of a novel yeah that's
what i'm saying it was a house built in
1880 there was a willow tree in the
front uh the maximum score you can get
on an act is 36 this dude
yeah damn yeah we did we yeah we had to
look that up before anything in the 30s
is is good
wait so there was a barn on your
property we had a barn that was uh
designated a historical site by the the
state of colorado really and then
mysteriously
on christmas day it burnt down it was
filled with hot dogs
because jack now says revenge
i'll get those talents one way or
another
those wily talent
yeah it burnt out was written in ketchup
on the side of your hand
uh why was it a historical thing was
there what significance did it happen
why was it burned down let's start there
no one knows but i do know that we got a
big check
and i i don't know anyway it was the one
time ever that we spent the night at my
aunt's house on christmas and then we
came home and my mom and dad were like
oh my god the barn's gone
yeah wow yeah but they got cleared of
any arson charges oh thank god so yeah
the insurance came through you ever been
to disney world
disneyland
we weren't a world family um [ __ ]
when did this happen what year i think
this happened when i was it's probably
1990 between six and eight all right
yeah so you're in the clear now oh yeah
yeah stat shoots yeah you're good so you
burn the burn down yeah
and they built my mama as a big like uh
country living better homes and gardens
enthusiast so she built this house with
the cash it ended up just being the
party house for uh for all my friends
and for my sister's friend so you have a
second house on the property and there's
a there's a little shack that my grandpa
built in retirement because he just like
to build homes wow so he built a little
house out there where uh my band would
practice
multiple i'm telling properties
multiple property multiple dwellings on
the properties also also though the
entire place has been uh evaluated for a
sale
and it's not it's not like it's not what
you would expect it's the yeah we were
like oh my god it's gonna be my mom and
dad's retirement and then they were like
oh [ __ ] jesus yeah we gotta keep nursing
this teat okay yeah but the property is
nice itself despite the monetary value
and they could retire there they have
retired there okay yeah they've moved
into the uh the house that they built
and now we have a mushroom i've put my
brother-in-law in there for a mushroom
farm in the little house my grandpa
built and then they're renting out to a
family friend in the other home the home
that i grew up in is the one that
they're uh renting out damn i've got to
tell you man we got a game going here
because that's this is back and forth
that's very
yeah
very classy dichotomy brothers you
really are i'm everything all at once
the duality of man here um brush your
teeth in the shower
uh yeah okay yeah i prefer it do you
leave the toothbrush in there also
yeah leave it in there okay yeah
okay what's that mean
that's the trashiest way to do it oh you
leave it in there no
can you leave it on top of your wife's
tooth uh you gotta take it out yeah you
assert dominance in small ways
through a cold war i don't know who runs
the shower yeah
uh what about sleeping how many pillows
you use when you sleep i use uh one
under the head and then one i sleep on
my side and i have one for the arm to
throw over nice all right all right
that's gonna have a fan directly on you
yes yes directly on you at all times
only on my side of the bed right my wife
hates the fan i have it right on me okay
i like that white noise circular fan the
one that moves around oscillating is it
oscillating or is it directly on you
while you sleep it oscillates okay it
goes from head to toe yeah that's there
you go yeah now real scum bags you have
it we have it right on you no you gotta
you gotta keep the feet cool too yeah
colorado's so dry that it just you it
burns crushing your nostrils central
central air in the house no ac units ac
yeah one upstairs in the bedroom to uh
do you sleep with any sort of weapon
near you uh yeah
what is it i mean how and how near what
proximity like
in case someone comes into the middle of
the night you're prepared yeah yeah what
is it there's a handgun yeah
he's
staring through me as he says that
[Laughter]
i love it
have you ever handed trash to the person
at the drive-thru when you were getting
food what
have you
i'm asking the questions here i'm asking
the gentleman from colorado i have given
cups to the starbucks lady i'll be like
can you take these and it's like four
starbucks cups and then a static big
gulp that i didn't know
all right that's trash if it's their
product oh no yeah i feel like they
should take the corporate policy by the
way let's not bring your trash back
tomorrow tell you what the corporate
policy is the group policy is no they
don't do it because of germs they don't
want germs oh yeah they hate it yeah
they're not stoked that's crazy to me
that's gonna answer your question i was
in the car with somebody who tried it
once yeah i've done that move yeah i was
alone in the car i didn't know that was
even trash
oh god
um let's see uh when was the last time
you slept in your jeans
never wear jeans oh what do you sleep in
uh completely nude completely new yeah
yeah no undies no nothing look at them
yeah cause the undies make a real humid
rainforest situation down below sure i
like to wake up dry all right yeah fresh
yeah i don't want to wear a diaper to
sleep i can't see it but i don't wear
pants not all shorts all the time you
don't wear pants in general as a rule
yeah i think i own one pair of pants in
there for weddings and funerals what
kind of pants are they uh like trout
like slacks they're costco blue chinos
okay we're getting there yeah
my dad was so keen on not wasting any
money that he would wear one pair of
shorts cut off sweatshorts
and then they would have a hole in the
crotch so he'd wear another pair on top
that also had a hole in a different part
so it makes one pair one pair yeah that
was like the big talk of the town
because my dad was my football coach
until eighth grade and all my friends
would be like oh yeah dave talent wears
two pairs of shorts huh
all right yeah we are getting there
we're getting there yeah really getting
there the fact that your dad was your
football coach too oh small town i get
it we were dominant
we didn't lose a game in three years
hmm
uh at any point in your life you ever
have you ever carried around a zippo
oh yeah i tried zippos yeah
you always gotta give it away i tried so
hard they're tough to play
yeah yeah and it's back in the day when
i had zero money so when you lost that
zippo it was just like the end of the
world you'd be yelling at your
girlfriend like i know you had it yeah
what what was the
design or color motorhead logo yeah yeah
it was yeah it was yeah
i tell you they come in strong
the house always wins gang couple of
tense moments now he's cracking open
you store anything in the oven
what
do you store anything in your oven
yeah we store the uh
baking sheet in there yeah and then when
you roast vegetables i like to leave
them in there overnight so i can have
them for lunch in the morning
it's like we roasted brussels sprouts
before i left and i was like baby left
the turkey and the brussels sprouts in
the oven the turkey yeah i'd like to
roast half a turkey here and there sure
i understand that but yeah i understand
the roasting it's the leaving it leaves
the turkey in the oven overnight yeah
no i don't know i don't think that's not
sam and then she just turns on the heat
and it's good to go uh-uh that's not
you can't do that at a restaurant no
have you ever gotten violently ill from
this i mean i've been violently ill from
food yeah i live with diarrhea dogs me
too man well that's probably why i
stopped leaving the meatloaf in the oven
for a week well you might have a point
touche fellow mage
[Laughter]
you know my wife's a doctor she says
it's okay as long as you crank it to 350
for like 10 minutes
holy sh but then you got dry bird that's
going to be your biggest issue oh that's
been a problem for me for quite some
time i know i heard this correctly right
they cook turkey and brussels sprouts
the night before
and then they'll just leave it in the
oven leave the remnants in there
overnight
i i'm not gonna sit here and say i
haven't done something along those lines
oh yeah cause then you gotta get a
tupperware out put it all in there put
it back on the baby what a gentleman a
gentleman would do that though i mean
we're it's this we're so busy
who has tupperware time yeah come on
this work a day life
is tired of putting your food in the
refrigerator
wasting all the excess hours kenmore
it's another fridge
it's a room temperature fridge
it's a food tomb
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] have you ever made your own
moonshine no but i've drank moonshine on
many occasions
jack is what you call it or you put
cider in
and then you uh freeze it and then you
scrape off the top and that's like pure
liquor pretty much
jesus christ man i've made my own cider
and mead before when i lived on the
commune in upstate new york we'd make
our own mead oh i'm sorry one second
toby pull that back five seconds
real quick the commune in upstate new
york yeah what
please
that's that
my best friend moved to uh to attend
school in ithaca uh at ithaca college
and i was very disenfranchised with
college so i would drop out move up
there we would we had our band and then
we would tour when he wasn't in school
and we lived on an anarchist commune
called goblin house where we killed our
own chickens uh you know dumpster
sacrifices food yeah yeah you know just
so we get hard
to honor the moon
so the rock gods would bless us yeah and
then we made honeymead and uh and like
plum wine applejack
holy [ __ ] yeah these kids live the life
it was fun man it was just an lsd fueled
freak show for a while and what years
was this from from when this was on and
off from 2006 to 2010. damn why don't
you graduated yeah how old are you now
i'm 34. oh really holy [ __ ] i know i
look weathered not even that's just the
stories alone i thought you were 72.
well you aged faster in the old west
yeah exactly yeah
when the dentist is also the
veterinarian
and the barber
ever have breakfast in bed
yeah
not like the romantic way like you're
eating like hash browns while watching
tv dinner in bed for sure dinner in bed
yeah in the house you live in now with
your wife you guys have had dinner in
bed uh so we moved a month ago but the
previous home yes okay i've had she's
not doing it sure but like if she's
working overnight and i got the house to
myself it's fair game yeah it's there's
no rules it's a godless place when she's
not there so i'm just in there uh i
think the last thing i had in bed bef
here's how i'll quantify it eating and
then putting the plate on the nightstand
and then going straight to bed oh it's
my favorite and it was a manicotti
wow that is before a nap that'll put you
under that's like a tranq dark how long
was it after 9 00 p.m
how long was that sitting in the inn it
was in there when we moved in
previous owners yeah i'd give it a shot
that's beautiful all right uh when was
the last time you had fish sticks
i i i've had okay good question i was in
fargo north dakota last weekend and i
had a fish sandwich that seemed to just
be you know your classic fish stick
patty
yeah it was terrible yeah where where'd
you get it did you make it yourself or
do you order it somewhere no i got it
like at the bar after the show when i
was like halfway wasted wow you know
what you know what goes with 17 miller
lights yes a bar fish sandwich oh my god
yeah
a couple of ah man what was your what
was your mom's specialty growing up what
kind of dinners would you have it would
be like a talent family my mom did not
cook who cooked my father could cook my
diet he would cook a roast chicken but
my grandpa and grandma provided the food
for most of us really your grandma and
grandpa living with you when you grew up
no no but they lived in town and after
school i would go to their house until
my mom and dad got off work okay and
then i would i would go there on my off
hours and eat lunch in my grandpa's
house because he was like my grandpa was
a hobo back in the day he would actually
ride [ __ ] dude
like actual hobo like out like during
the depression he would hop a train from
uh
st joe missouri and ride out to
philadelphia and work in the factories
and then come home drop off the checks
or the cash and then hop a train back to
the east coast and work who are you yeah
this is nuts are you a time traveler no
i swear to god he might be we're just
you know you guys are east coast and
things are weird out on the west you
know sure but i mean i mean i think
they're weird as a talent house yeah
i don't know if i throw kind of
i don't know that's all out west why
don't i throw the heartland under the
bus it gets stranger my grandpa was
named over talent
over over talent ova and he swears that
he was named after a man during previous
before the depression who would ride
town to town
and he would have the townsfolk gather
up stray dogs
stake them to the ground and then for
like a penny you could watch him fight
the stray dogs and he was named after
this guy jesus and which that that
sounds like the most insane like you
know it sounds like a lie but he swore
to that that he was named after a dog
fighting hobo named ova
damn yeah that's a first here on ayg i
feel i thought i was thrown off by your
grandparents feeding you oh yeah
yeah your grandmother made your lunch
how was that strap you're telling me
almost every meal was there uh yeah a
lot of times lunch and dinner were there
and then we would have family meals it
was fam dinner time was a big deal so if
we weren't eating at grandpa and
grandma's we'd eat at home and my mom
would put some [ __ ] together that was no
good or my dad would make his patented
lemon roast chicken okay yeah but they
let you have milk with dinner oh we're
not a milk family really i am
stunned yeah not not bad what would you
what would you drink at dinner water we
had well water the best water ever which
we've learned we thought it was trashy
but well water is scientifically proven
to be way better we had our own well and
it's just like whenever i go home i am
pounding water at my parents house
that's the greatest really no soda in
the household at all
no no soda uh because me and my sister
were big you know pant loads so they
were trying to let's pant loads big fat
kids okay
i was a fat kid too yeah you know you
just as well my doctor says clinically
obese
so
yeah so they were trying to like make
healthy choices but that did not we
would have power aid in the house which
turns out is poison well in the 90s that
you thought that was good the experiment
the electrolytes yeah
they had they had the whole [ __ ]
country bamboozled on electrolytes not
gatorade but powering powerade uh and
then also i remember just drinking like
those cartons of orange juice all the
time like the fold ones yeah yeah i had
a fridge in my bedroom holy hell yeah
full size
[Laughter]
it was a walk-in double doors
my first job i saved up when i bought a
fridge and i bought the clapper and i
put it in my room oh my that's that's
insane
he bought it his first his first
purchases were the clapper yeah and a
fridge for his bedroom your parents were
okay with you having a fridge in your
room i don't know what did you what did
you put in there uh a lot of lunch meat
lunch meat spray cheese and uh
yeah
i'm with you on the spray cheese big guy
yeah i'm a [ __ ]
i was banksy with that stuff i think i
was 15. yeah lunch meat yeah a lot of uh
you know that the 50 cent uh bunting
lunch meat uh-huh yeah yeah those are
big i i don't know what that what
bunting it's lunch meat doesn't matter
what the boy said 50 cents that's what
threw me the 50 cent packets he has
lunch meat in his room as he i don't
even know what my mom didn't even have
the good they didn't have the good lunch
meat it wasn't like he was keeping his
private reserve i didn't have to leave
my room it was great
your parents were okay with this my
parents said that it was my money and i
could spend it on whatever i wanted and
where a lot of kids were buying like a
dream cast or an n64 i was like i want a
refrigerator up there so i never have to
see any people i want some buffalo chips
were you making sandwiches in there no
dude out of the packet so the packet
then would you put the spray cheese on
the piece of lunch meat and you would
would you spend a lot of time in there i
would assume you spent a lot of time in
your room yeah yeah okay of course i had
everything i needed yeah i mean what are
you talking about yeah
holy [ __ ] wells as well doesn't run dry
i'm golden oh yeah did the well of a
well ever go bad no no no never did well
what happened is that what it's called
tainted well i believe so yeah and when
that happens does it eventually clean
itself out or is that it for the well no
you have to uh you have to plunge it
because like usually what happens when a
well goes bad is an animal will die in
the water they'll fall in the well and
die
and then that ruins everything so you
have to get down there and
get them out pull it all out of there so
not to sound ignorant but a well the
water's coming up from the ground yeah
right natural natural spring from the
ground and so it's there is movement in
there it's not just stagnant water yeah
it's new water and it's also purified by
like limestone or something right
natural aquifer it's cleaned by stones
okay so it's not like it's in dirt
i mean i'm not an excavator
i drank the water that came out of the
tap and it was yummy
and my dad if you go visit my dad's
house the first thing i'll say is best
damn water in the world
did you ever play by the train tracks
growing up was that a thing didn't have
train tracks downtown yeah i would have
liked to of course
that was the big go-to what's that
culvert's like a tunnel under a road oh
yeah those are a good time you find one
of those we play tunnel town hang out
down there that was our big game as a
kid was it like a seat like a system of
tunnels or just like one one big tunnel
right underneath highway 86 what was the
game just hang out in the tunnel but it
was called tunnel town you know okay so
you guys like try to it's not like this
you tried to do like the sims we didn't
build our own society
yeah there wasn't a school board or
anything yeah i got to be honest that's
what i really know we didn't have an hoa
[Laughter]
county commission keeping meeting
minutes and [ __ ]
any magicians in the family
[Music]
no
dude that's crazy yeah
i mean you tell us about tunnel town and
all of a sudden i'm a jerk off
any magicians no dude my dad legendary
pulled the thumb off guys
that was his go-to move when he was a
substitute teacher initially he'd whip
his thumb off and there was this kid
named cameron rau who thought he could
actually do it until like we graduated
high school was he a substitute teacher
in your school uh in the middle school
by the time he he i only had him once
and he was for gym class okay and then
by the time he was doing that uh he was
a special needs teacher initially and
then
substitute teacher for a couple years
and then became a fourth grade teacher
at a charter school where he like
graduated retired from
there is such a duality it's wild it's
it's crazy i mean it does i guess it
doesn't sound weird until you know
someone else sees i mean it's you guys
are a mirror held up to my experience
it's actually it's kind of fantastic to
be honest with you because there's you
know there is that garbage element but
like yes you know was an alcoholic gets
himself out of that special needs
teacher yeah gives back to the community
football yeah coach and all that kind of
stuff yeah and he was a football coach
while he was still having a sweet sip or
two he used to pick me up with a red dog
funny answer drive me home and a red dog
yeah you know right i mean those red
ales no no no that was killian's irish
rabbits
they came heavy in the [ __ ] 90s yeah
a lot of branding it was like a red pit
bull or like uh boxers i believe it's
made by milwaukee's best it's their like
pbr sub brand i believe that i don't
think it's still around either oh you
can get it oh yeah in chicago yeah oh
i've never seen it i had a question but
i'm sure it's going to be a yes and it's
have you gone to high school football
games where no family member was playing
oh yeah yeah of course oh yeah i went to
a high school football game last year
and i called the uh the a.d and was like
hey can i come on the field and they
were like it's covid and i was like
and they were like come on down
really yeah i went on the field wore my
letter jacket holy sh [ __ ] 33 years old
[Laughter]
wild move
that's pretty nice wow yeah and everyone
on the local news for any reason yeah
i was in the denver post as a child
because they just they did a thing about
men who stayed home to raise their kids
because my mom had the better job so
when i was born my dad quit his job
stayed home to raise me she had that fed
money yeah exactly yeah uh-huh so yeah i
was before i had memories i was in the
denver post
but i was in the local newspaper a lot
for like you know honor roll football
that kind of [ __ ] okay not too bad not
too bad
ever recommend a book to somebody that
you didn't read
no
um i recommend books i love books i read
a lot of literature so if someone wants
me to recommend a book i give them like
a sincere like i think you would
actually like this because when people
read books you don't want to waste their
time like if they're actually going to
take a chance on a book you want them
you want it to be yeah yeah they click
god damn it he's pulling himself out of
it
because that's really classy i don't
know yeah i mean yeah okay uh magician
thing that's where i lost it
do you know how to tie a tie i'm
assuming no uh i wear bolo ties wow yeah
okay i don't know if i've ever worn a
regular tie except for my wedding or my
uncle tied that for me now is that kind
of the thing out there bolo ties
wouldn't nobody would bat an eye at that
no yeah yeah yeah but if you went to a
wedding out here for like a comic or
something like that you'd rock the bowl
and you'd wear those one pair of pants
no i would i mean i if someone's having
a sweet special memory i don't want to
be the guy who is in the photos looking
like [ __ ] so i will like go to the nines
for people's uh big big deals you know
cool man that's
real classical i heard you guys talking
about attending that lady's wedding and
you're gonna you know dress up yeah we
just just got back we got back yesterday
but i was just when you said you know i
have one pair of pants i'm staunch on
wearing shorts i didn't know if you
broke that rule for anybody no it's not
about me it's about her wow you know
that's [ __ ] good garbage would be
like yeah man i don't do it i'll you
know i'll show up at khakis and uh
eagles jerseys just so try hard to be
trash it is like you're gonna wear the
t-shirt with the tuxedo on it that's
hack that's been done to death there
might have been somebody at the wedding
with that happening oh yeah and it was
like my head exploded
i was sitting next to paul versus he's
like you believe this people he was
[ __ ] he was in the back row losing it
whatever happened to the cow with the
blueberry oh they slaughtered it for
meat really yeah one day it wasn't there
wow and then we got a side of beef like
two weeks later ouch tastes like
blueberries yeah that's good yeah
yeah a little bit of milk nothing wrong
with it
mike and these the marshmallows
that's colorado wagyu
just to jump back to that did you have
other friends in the neighborhood or was
it really no i mean it was so like when
you were solo with your sister and the
lunch meat and the lunch meat all right
so now the lunch meat makes a little
more sense yeah we didn't have to like
that that long soju into town and the
wagon train you know right
who would you hang out well you said who
would you play tunnel town with oh that
would be when i was at my aunt's house
or my uncle my aunt and my grandpa live
right next door to each other in town so
i had my cousins and the kids from the
neighborhood would play tunnel town
there was also a big uh mound of dirt
that we would go play on top of and play
king of the hill but they weren't really
they were your they were like
adjacent friends does that make sense
they weren't like your buddies no no
like they were they were the kids in
town so like you know you had the ragtag
bunch of kids who would hang out and
chase the hoop down the street did you
grow up with them and become like
friends of them in high school and all
that stuff like were they they were
older than me so i mean i guess they
were adjacent they were my cousin's
friends then i would go along with them
and they would make me smoke cigarettes
and like look at porno
yeah pretend to enjoy it garbage yeah i
got you here right yeah all right that
makes sense so the cow really was
one of your best friends yeah for sure
and then they slaughtered it they killed
it jesus for sustenance they like my
parents grew up on county road 150 like
that's how far out in the county we were
damn yeah
bonkos
i'm not even sure what that means the
higher the number the further out no
it's just like you know some people grow
up on like blueberry or sorry like i got
blueberry brain you know you have like
fun names for gotcha you were it was
more count yeah that's why that's what
was my first question but i don't want
to ask you because you said that they
lived there yeah so that well yeah
that's that's trash yeah it's not like
you know uh blueberry lane wood maple
circle or something nice and also
everyone in elizabeth knows where the
talents live okay is that small of a
community and they've been there for so
long
i love that i love that it's so so
family like the town everybody knows
where the talents live everybody has the
same profession in the other family
who's the biggest family in town who's
the richest family in town since really
yeah those [ __ ] yeah 100 the
christensens
bart christensen lovely guy mormon
family lds he was one of my basketball
coaches and he had like nine kids and
they all became dentists he was a
dentist they would go on mission
chad chad christensen was in my grade
good friend of mine
legendary dick
really packing heat dude my friend
amanda was dating him in high school i
was student council president and we
were having like a student council
meeting i remember one of the girls
melanie was like amanda what's chad's
dick like and she was like i don't know
you know it's like uh
just like doing this thing and you're
like what the [ __ ] i would have started
with length
he was a [ __ ] talk in a red dog
real quick sam's like meeting adjourned
yeah exactly
and you're a liar
burn this [ __ ] she needs to be
committed
i'm pouting
are there any long-standing beefs yeah
oh yeah yeah the loonies everyone hates
the loonies of course yeah i mean what
on brand name for that
those goddamn loonies down there yeah
carl looney was the town drunk and he
would just rub everyone the wrong way
but they had this place kevin looney was
a year younger than me and they had the
crab shack where you could go and smoke
weed and cigarettes whenever you want
because carl didn't give a [ __ ] about
what kids were up to oh the crab shack
was like a house on their prop like it
was just like it's made of aluminum
siding
oh yeah is that why it's called a crab
check or was that just another name you
guys gave it no that's just the name
that i knew it as you know is that now
everything's got a little name yeah does
every would somebody else have a craft
or that was the name of that
there was one unique crab shadow okay it
was on the loonies what a cool name for
that and every now and then carl would
come in and be like tough guys rule and
then he would go fall down somewhere
this guy sounds like a straight sugar if
you ask me he was cool yeah he'd buy us
beer if we bought him beer
shout out to the loonies it sounds like
a pretty good pretty good town to grow
up here it was great man it's a
self-sustaining economy for a drunk
you buy me a couple
a lot of violence oh yeah just like
fights at the skate park type [ __ ] yeah
yeah probably tough kids too really
hurting each other yeah like cracking
jaws and stuff the worst one
i'm not gonna say his name but uh there
was a fight between like
the jocks and the and the skaters
whatever you want to call them the kids
who smoked weed and i was like in
between so i had to go but i couldn't
pick a side and luckily this kid showed
up and he they were he was the toughest
one so everyone piled on him and he just
pulled out a can of bear mace covered
his face and spawned in a circle and
mace like 35 people all at once and that
was the end of that pretty [ __ ] sweet
it was a cool move
he's using technology yeah
yeah that's chemical warfare
i got nothing wrong with that yeah
that's fantastic
there's nothing else to do besides like
fighting of course you're a pretty big
guy or the other big big guys in town no
i was the biggest you were the biggest
dude in town did you have to fight a lot
no because uh the beauty of where i came
from is the fact that like there were
really no sectarian
beefs like if you were a cowboy or you
ended up being a goth or whatever we all
went to school from kindergarten on so
it's like andy quinn might be king of
the rodeo but i do remember when he you
know [ __ ] his pants in second grade on
the field
so it's like everything's like a family
kind of yeah everybody knows everybody's
skeletons in the closet yeah you could
never become too cool because like we
were pants
yeah
huh i like that but like colton mason
andy quinn there were some big cowboy
dudes and uh luckily i never rubbed them
the wrong way because they were very
very good at violence
[Laughter]
louise says that i know
his word choices i'm fascinated i'm
talking to crazy joe divola
i welcome intruders
there's been sentences i'm supposed to
be the smart guy on the podcast they're
saying you said where i'm like i got
nothing on that
yeah i'm still not really sure what
sectarian yeah that sectarian beef i
literally thought it was an animal
you get that with brene sauce
you leave that in the oven overnight
what are we doing um what was the
sideburn situation
it seems pretty
seems pretty serious
in the town as a whole
no was there is this on brand with the
town no i was i was the mutton shop guy
okay so was there any dads or teachers
or family members that didn't have
sideburns a lot of people did not have
side like i mean like where you notice
it where like they have none where they
go high like above the east you know
what i'm talking about you know what you
mean like that permanent bowl cut type
stuff crazy yeah no there was a lot of
that going really yeah and then there
was people who were didn't give a [ __ ]
and would have beard some days and then
they would sure cut it down a little bit
okay but i don't think they were a
permanent fixture the no sideburns thing
i've seen some dads that try to rock
that where it's literally like just a
straight line here completely shaved
yeah it's like an alien tried to make a
human yes yeah yeah yeah it's bad when
they don't get the hair cut on the sides
they just trim you see them trim the the
sideburns themselves and you're like you
went too high on them right yeah yeah or
the back do you ever see them do it
themselves on the back those guys are
always wearing oakley's yeah mm-hmm yeah
it's heinous all right so that was a lot
of that you're saying i think that side
because it was you know it's still a
kind of a cowboy town
kind of like trying to look cool yeah
you know toby would have got dragged
behind a truck oh man yeah for sure if
they could have caught me i'd be skating
pretty fast oh yeah
yeah you would have been happy
it would have to be a ford or something
to get me yeah
uh have you ever worn a neck brace
no okay never had a neck brace
luckily no had injuries growing up it's
good this is a question that i don't
think i could ask anyone else but have
you ever seen someone get a bone set not
in a hospital yes uh ryan adams broke
his arm
ninth grade football and uh my coach was
like one two and on two he snapped it
back in and those screams still echo in
my brain
it was horrendous dude
yeah
i broke my arm one time my dad was
always big on you jammed it that's just
jammed it's not broken you jammed it and
i broke my hand and he's like let me see
it it's just jammed it [ __ ] broke the
bone in half and he just yanked it three
times like oh that was gonna do it
surgery the next day yeah
yeah my dad would say you tweaked it
tweaked it yeah yeah that's a real big
deal
it's like a dirtbag thing yeah just you
jammed it you tweaked it yeah you got a
compound tweak yeah yeah yeah yeah you
tweaked it through the skin you jammed
it so much i can see the bone
you're internally tweaking don't worry
about it you'll be fine
um
will you sing happy birthday
to another table when they start singing
happy birthday in a restaurant love it
i'll join in right away yeah you'll join
in right away love it yeah do you have a
rap you know do the whole thing yeah now
do you ever say it's somebody's birthday
at your table to get a free dessert oh
i've embarrassed so many people with the
birthday thing okay i love it it's a
google now is it strictly just for
embarrassment is it for the free pie
it's for the embarrassment okay that'll
i'll i'll let slide if it's for the free
cake yeah it's a tough look a minute
that's a fringe
i'm not saying it's not i'm not turning
it away of course um we lightly touched
on a lot i want to say
we lightly touched on disneyland yeah so
that's where where would where would the
talents go on a family vacation what
would that look like my mom we would go
to tallest new mexico because my
grandma's from wagon mountain new mexico
she's the old mexican lady and we had
land near wagon mound right around taos
pueblo we'd go down he's throwing names
out that i got nothing on you're saying
it like it's albuquerque
it's two hours north albuquerque how
much land
uh it's tough to tell because it was
like thousands of acres well my grandma
didn't know like her family the
esquivels didn't know that they were
american until like a census guy wrote
up to give them mail for the first time
like they were so deep in the caves
um so there's a lot of acreage down
there but we don't know really who owns
what there's like a couple families who
are just like you have access to it do
whatever you want damn yeah but my mom
tried to class us up a bunch like one
time we went to like montreal and one
time we went to boston and we'd go to
like an island in florida that was you
know how would you get to boston would
you guys fly we would fly except for
certain like my mom's from cleveland so
we would drive to cleveland every summer
okay that was always terrible what kind
of car are we talking
pathfinders that's not bad pathfinders
are all right
yeah yeah i thought you're rolling like
a horse wagon or something yeah i wish
yeah two people died of dysentery the
first time
we were tainted well yeah
my dad would buy five-year-old
pathfinders every five years
how's his move it's pretty smart burn
him to the ground
it's pretty smart yeah did he know how
to fix it if something went wrong not at
all really yeah the talents are reversed
to cars i don't give a [ __ ] about cars
interesting yeah i had my i got my oil
changed like every two weeks and they're
like you know you still got like 75 oil
in here and i'm like
fellas
i'm just glad to stimulate the economy
i'm driving a 2009 chevy impala right
not bad i bought my wife a bronco
the new ones they're pretty cool i just
saw one yesterday just point your way
for broncos yeah she wanted one not bad
you bought her at least
it's the only brag that i can really do
i love it throw it out there baby
um
i think i got a couple more that we
could get in some patreon 100
um
i'm assuming no but any in your family
own their own pool cue
no okay no oh they own their own frisbee
golf discs okay that's worse
[Laughter]
my dad one time talk about tripling down
god damn my dad came down one time uh
very early in the morning and he's like
betsy good news
i'm going to arizona and i'm going to
join the professional disc golf tour
and she was this in the drinking days
yes i think it was okay yeah and then
she was like dave you have to go to work
and that's the first time i ever saw my
dad like broken really yeah he went
upstairs put on live at leads and just
played drums for like three hours
plays a drum's your father and so do i
he's a renaissance man
i mean
i mean frisbee golf and the drums what
are we doing he's about to be the john
daly of the frisbee [ __ ] circus but
we can't overlook the fact that you just
said he went upstairs to play the drums
yeah so there was a room designated the
drum room in your home my room had the
drum set in it so he would go into your
room yeah whenever he wanted now let me
ask you this
are they allowed to go into the fridge
and take some lunch meat if they want it
no
really oh yeah i mean they could have
but i would have been blown away if they
would touch that fetted lunch meat that
[ __ ] was in here forever and every like
three months i'd open it up and forget i
had some lunch meat in there and it
would reek and i'd have to take it
outside hose it down bring it back up
man hosing down a mini fridge
in the yard that is a bad there's no way
that just hit you in the face one day
that was seeping through the room for at
least a couple of weeks oh the room was
a nightmare
i'm now picking up on that yeah it was a
graveyard i had spitters because i
couldn't smoke cigs during football so
i'd have like old spitters i'd lose and
like find underneath the bed every now
and then oh my god yeah you ever shower
and put dirty put dirty clothes on of
course
yes
can you say with certainty that every
member of your family has at least once
had the dish known as eggs benedict yeah
yeah not bad yeah it's pretty good pets
growing up other than the cow yep we had
uh golden retrievers growing up nice
that's the classiest dog
would you have pear always just no one
dog and it would just have it would you
know it'd be gone for two days and then
come back just a farm dog situation
really yeah i want to get back to the
frisbee
where did that come from your dad was
like i'm going to go to new mexico to be
in
that seems like a hair brain scheme was
that like in the works and then he just
completely was like now you're right i
got to go away and why did he think he
could go pro that quickly my dad's very
good my dad's a very skilled frisbee
golfer so he was playing it for a long
time oh yeah because uh there was a
frisbee golf course in my town
elizabeth's very weird yeah he was part
of the brush fire rebellion so the brush
fire rebellion was a bunch of hippies
moved to small towns in eastern colorado
in the 70s and 60s took over the town uh
council and then implemented whatever
laws and legislation they wanted to put
in place
so there was like an undercurrent of
hippie [ __ ] when my dad was there
because he grew up there he went to the
same school as i did you know damn um
so they had frisbee golf courses and you
know there was like a house called
pomegranate where people would go and
smoke weed and stuff but
uh and then when you know the 80s
happened people moved in because it was
a nice place to be and sure that was all
obliterated
he's very good still very good at
frisbee golf really so he could have it
that's like a scratch frisbee golf
player
[Laughter]
oh okay
making all this up could he be making
all this up man if he had i'm [ __ ] in
yeah i don't know i i i'm sold and
confused and a little hot i don't know
what's happening
i wouldn't mind checking out the real
estate out there
have you guys ever busted anyone lying
on here no no no sounds like a wild move
i like how you said busted yeah yeah
this guy's never had a slim jim in his
life
i don't even you've never even tasted
mountain dew he's flossing all the time
three-month-old lunch meet my ass
what were the names of the golden
retrievers we had auggie we had jessie
and we had chloe
all pretty legit pet names how do you
feel about root beer
big fan a w straight off the tap yeah
good stuff
know you ever call anybody mate no
nothing pisses me off more yeah you ever
say cheers to something dude shut up
yeah
nothing makes me more mad than when
someone's like hey do you know how to
get to the walgreens and you're like
yeah go up take a left and they're like
cheers like shut the [ __ ] up yeah
you're not from there yeah it's tough
it's i mean it seriously makes my blood
boil that and people not going fast in
the left lane will make me lose it the
worst is if you have like a friend who
goes to europe and then comes back and
they start saying cheers you're like
dude what are we doing yeah check that
[ __ ] at jfk all right
or like uh if the meal comes they're
like abandoned oh you're like you go eat
in the car yeah
[Laughter]
all right the kid checks out for me yeah
um all right let's run through a couple
of patreon i'm leaning towards class can
i say that no you can't i don't know man
he's pretty good
wow
pretty good he's just a verbose hobo
dude you just like the fact that he
likes root beer
i'll tell you what the lunch meat in the
room is it's not sounding that crazy to
me anymore dude spraying down a mini
fridge in your yard you can't come back
from that everybody so he's so well
spoken and articulate yeah don't that's
he's trying to fool you there's so much
detail no
thin veneer
he doesn't know what that means
i mean the teeth
i know what a veneer is
are you doubling down on this
they're blinds yeah that's right
venerations there you are
[Laughter]
all right uh guys so as you know when
you join the patreon we will ask uh your
garbage question it's just the best way
to do it uh this one's from ireland but
i guess we did we learned do you sleep
with socks on no no completely nude
there
um okay this is from tj ever had to get
tetanus or a rabies shot oh tetanus
shots a lot yeah yeah yes there's
yeah
first rule tunnel town yeah
that's not that garbage
people kids step on nails and stuff a
lot of barbed wire cuts too that's
that's a little crazy what the [ __ ] you
gotta get in the old air force base
somehow well yeah just everyone had
barbed wire fences so you'd be sneaking
around you know just in the properties
from bears and stuff like that uh i
don't know why they never see a bear
i've never seen a bear really yeah but
there was deer just constantly my mom
shoots deer with bb guns all the time
on the property yeah yeah yeah yeah
have you ever have you ever peed on an
electric fence yes
yes uh to impress kathleen job
did it work shock you oh it [ __ ] me up
shot goes right up to penis yeah it was
bad damn yeah did it did was she
impressed did you steal the deal or
anything no she was flipped out man
cause i started crying
[Laughter]
she was my hot neighborhood [ __ ] nerd
talent when it played cool
yeah i got tased at a party to impress a
girl in college one time someone broke
out a taser and i'm like show like this
have you ever actually gone cow tipping
is like oh yeah really oh yeah a lot
that was a fun thing to do you have to
run you can't just go up and push them
you have to run and put your shoulder
into them
sometimes they die
what yeah because it's such a shock to
their system they're like heart stops
have you ever killed a cow i haven't but
the raiders
there's blood on their hands
started a town war
shoot out of tunnel town it was messy
they never found the gatlin boy
when you're riding shotgun is it scatter
gun or repeater we call it scatter guns
is that a thing scatter guns yeah like a
tommy gun
shotgun the shotgun's a scatter gun
because the spray scatters out here's
the last question i'll ask okay
did anyone get some root beer
[Laughter]
where are the [ __ ] hot dogs
the lights go off
[Laughter]
has anybody in your town ever
disappeared
uh yeah yeah i think that's accurate and
i mean i when it's disappeared it's like
they probably just they left it was a
choice probably yeah yeah um i don't
think anyone's been like
disappeared yeah you know i don't think
the verb has happened there's never been
like a kid that went missing i
uh not to my knowledge
yeah
i thought that was going to go a little
bit further but fair enough yeah sorry
man yeah
hey kidnapping how do you like it
this isn't a larry mcmurtry
i don't know what that is
what a pulitzer
i don't even know what that is
[Laughter]
pulitzer i don't even know her
that's a good piece of business
big wordplay guy i don't care who you
are
all right i got two more here um
this is from cole everywhere dog tags as
a kid no dude yeah i was a big dog tax
guy not stealing valor
brave men and
an eight-year-old i don't women anybody
would think that
people are saluting me at the moment
we're in the front lines of tunnel town
yeah
we had a standing militia
oh yeah you folks know the american flag
flies over tunnel town
it's at half mass we ran out of gushers
it was a sad day
all right uh last one for me uh this is
from connor haven't had one ass yet have
you ever you ever drive shirtless oh
yeah really yeah that's a bad luck yeah
home from football practice every day
all right that makes sense but ah i
remember i got kind of buff my senior
year and it was like a big deal that i
went through the sonic drive through
with my shirt off i was like feeling
good about myself yeah
sonic which was your fast food that was
the only fastest did you handle
mcdonald's trash when you when you got
there mcdonald's was an hour away wait
sonic was the only
fast food in your town that was it
yeah sonic's great man
happy hour from four to six what does
that mean you got uh the 44 chicks
ladies drink free
girls can i buy you a slushie
yeah
there's no they serve booze there no no
it's just 44 ounce ocean water is like a
nickel or whatever ocean water yeah
what's that that's their sprite
derivative it tastes like sprite
yeah it's bright before right
it's like clear root beer
i was joking
she says
yeah he just hates sonic so much
interesting what do you have against
sonic the commercials commercials
okay so in our area for some reason they
just ran those sonic commercials over
and over again i mean like i don't know
how much they were dropping
all right but it was repetitive no sonic
we didn't get a sonic for like literally
15 years yeah but you guys have those
convenience stores they're like
restaurants you guys have like wawas
yeah yeah there's plenty of fantastic
options i'm not saying that but after
being beaten over the head with sonic
commercials for 15 years i finally go to
one and i thought it kind of stunk it's
not great
it was all we had there's only open
after 10 p.m in the town
damn yeah
that's so crazy i don't mind it they're
all right it's pretty good that's all
it's cracked up to be but they got
mozzarella sticks they do that's all i
need oh yeah tater tots instead of fries
no charge go crazy give it another whirl
mike ruiz was the manager and if you
showed up at like 11 59 he would just
give you all the tots and mozzarella
sticks they didn't sell that day in a
bag out the window that's a [ __ ] good
dude now you're now you're changing your
hair right now
you need to get a ruiz
man the plug going yeah what do you
think kip
i mean dude i was decided like 14
seconds in
the guy's [ __ ] trash
yeah he's refined in some ways he throws
fancy words at you to keep you on your
heels but
the kid's trash
you're still leaving sonic shirtless
with a bag of my friends yeah i mean on
the arm
on the cuff though
that guy never pays for a stick all
right
buddy thank you so much for coming and
sitting down with us man this was as
much fun as i hoped it would be wow this
was awesome we love you uh anything you
want the folks out there to know you got
coming up this that the other whatever
you want uh just buy my book from
samtalent.com t-a-l-l-e-n-t and follow
me on instagram which has been co-signed
by so many so many comedians yeah yeah
yeah it's so cool so kyle kane did the
forward did the forward yeah former
guest absolutely fantastic man yeah
and stan hope so yeah great guys thank
you for having me of course buddy thank
you kippy what do you got for him uh i'm
at kevin ryan comedy on all social media
uh
obviously itunes youtube and patreon and
then guys come to a [ __ ] live show uh
we just announced like [ __ ] 10 more
cities we're gonna be all over the
[ __ ] place come out there a good
[ __ ] time it's stamped me and the big
man needs to stand up and then we close
out the shows together taking your
questions from the audience it's [ __ ]
bonkos come check it out absolutely gang
we love you we'll see you next week
peace